vous avez un vrai cadeau Je veux que vous fassiez de
cet endroit un brun io 21 000 frais de scolarité dus
la semaine prochaine
Bienvenue dans le monde réel
J'ai perdu tout mon argent et je
découvre essentiellement qu'il y a un algorithme dans
le programme qui vous trompe et ne propose
vraiment aucune autre option que
d'aller au Costa Rica, vous avez la moindre idée à
quel point c'est fou c'est ma dernière chance
au lieu de siffler, je l'
apporte au bloc Ivan joué par Ben j'ai
été trompé sur votre site minuit noir
allé sur les forums Internet mais je ne
pensais pas à vous le jeu sur Internet est une
industrie de trente-cinq milliards de dollars par an c'est  juste partout dans le monde
depuis Dubaï au Costa Rica où ils peuvent
éviter les réglementations nationales américaines et la perte de
la maison menace toujours que ce genre
d'argent au milieu du Costa Rica
crée ce genre de dynamique folle qu'il
attire dans toutes les filles et le pari  les lers et les
arnaqueurs et il est au milieu de ça donc
il est capable d'être gentil attiré par
ce truc donc là c'est moins bien sûr
j'ai envie de rester et de tenter
le vrai business
je décris Ricci comme un gars dans le tort
le monde essaie de tout faire de la bonne
manière c'est mes remerciements à toi tu es avec
moi je suis
ce que le bloc veut sortir de Richey
c'est le manipuler pour qu'il ne
s'oppose pas à certaines des choses qui se
voient dans
les yeux  dans le business des enlèvements
maintenant fais ce que je veux et toi sur mon mec à l'
intérieur de beaucoup de tentations dans cette vie
et plus tu entres dans l'histoire
plus l'obscurité devient sombre tu as 48
heures pour me donner ce dont j'ai besoin en bloc
tu dis toi  peut me protéger
tu ne peux même pas protéger la seule source que
tu avais
laisse-moi y entrer Ivan tu veux
un travail plus sûr va travailler pour la poste
veux avoir bonne conscience va créer une
association caritative mais si tu veux ta propre île
et ton patron  dit que tu dois aller là-
bas et prendre une raclée  là-bas,
prends-le, reviens au travail et dis-tu, as-tu
besoin que je le fasse à nouveau comme une voix dans le
dos de ta tête en ce moment, ce n'est pas
ta conscience, c'est la peur